and if you're getting her cheese at
least get her some good damn cheese
a nice smoked gouda something from
france possibly
i'm just saying
all right everybody it is almost
valentine's day and i thought that we
would celebrate valentine's day or
singles awareness day whatever you
happen to be rocking with
y'all sending in horrible stories from
dates or valentine's
day kind of thing so let's see what
we've got here people
[Music]
i just love how this one starts my
ex-husband
forgot valentine's day one year he tried
to scramble to have flowers delivered
but couldn't get it done that day
he called my boss and had me put in a
conference room
at lunch he showed up with a whole
lobster that he had steamed at the
grocery store
he set it down in front of me said happy
valentine's day and then went back to
work
he left me sitting alone in a glass
conference room with a steamed lobster
and to make it worse
no butter
here's the thing he could have really
done well there and been like i'm so
sorry i forgot but i want to do this
specially and like at least
have lunch with her and here once again
too it's not about it's like
if you're gonna forget just say oh my
god i'm forgot let's do something cool
this weekend like to make up for you
know people forget what i forget stuff
like that
but like yeah just don't don't put any
effort unless it's gonna matter
[Music]
my then boyfriend of three years got me
a back three is a lucky number
right now of three years got me a bag of
string
cheese for for valentine's day and told
me
it's for you to eat when you're here in
the apartment alone
what kind of monster weaponizes cheese
like that
weaponizes jesus i love you val
um and also
just don't give her a gift like when you
have a gift
like it's better to just not give a gift
but yeah that's string cheese
what am i packing my lunch for
elementary school like i don't know why
you would do that
and if you're gonna get her cheese at
least get her some good damn cheese
a nice smoked gouda something from
france possibly
it's the best cheese i'm just saying
[Music]
received a bowling ball with no finger
holes
drilled in it and a balloon tied around
it
that was from a living boyfriend of
three years
we never went bowling wtf was he
thinking
didn't last long after that like what's
the message there
you know what i'm saying like that's so
you're just dead weight there's no way
to lift it you up
bye that's what i would have said too
[Music]
okay i've been married for 38 years
about 20 of those years on valentine's
day my husband would bring home one
single rose that's me
i would always put it in a little bud
vase and set it on
the coffee table for a week after about
20 years of this my husband looks at me
and says
boy those roses i i get really last a
long time
to which i replied they're fake
you should have seen the shocked look on
his face
what for 20 years you don't know the
difference between a fake rose and a
real rose
that's the bigger issue if you've taken
a walk
outside they're pretty different or
first of all what company is making
these roses that look that life-like
because i want them anyway that's all we
have time for today
um people just like i said like if
you're gonna try
go for it actually do it okay or just
don't at all
and say maybe this isn't my thing and
let's do something else to make it our
thing
you know um but own it and or just find
someone else
bye yep i'm still here just waiting for
you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help